I don't trust the Republican party I
mean not the leadership there are good
Republicans there are good members and
they're good candidates running this
cycle but what I struggle with is you
know here we go again we've had wave
elections in this country before 1994
2010 2016 we had the trifecta you know
White House both both chambers of
Congress and here we are again we're
talking about another wave election well
where did those three previous wave
elections get us right here so what's
going to be different about it this time
you know if we take the house you know
we'll have Kevin McCarthy as the speaker
if we take the Senate we'll have Mitch
McConnell as majority leader and I'm not
saying it's a good thing to have the
Democrats in full control for two more
years but you know I just want to hear
how this is going to be different this
time I agree and what frustrates me to
no end is we we don't treat our voters
with respect we don't treat the
right-leaning people in this country our
constituents we don't have the humility
to look them in the eye and say hey yeah
what we've been doing has been failing
and we're going to try something
different